I think it's one of the most gutless
vindictive and petty things I've ever
seen in English sport Kevin Pietersen
was directly told by Andrew Strauss his
incoming boss Colin grades ECB chairman
that if you want to get back in the
England team he had to go back to a
County and play county cricket and score
runs that's exactly what he's done he's
up the scored runs he's currently
averaging over 200 he scored three
hundred and fifty five not out in his
recent innings which ended this morning
he's in the form of his life according
to him and yet Andrew Strauss has shut
the door
that was opened by Andrews Frances boss
so understandably Kevin Peterson feels
extremely letdown betrayed and I believe
he thinks he's been lied to
you've spoken to him today I have spoken
to him throughout this process and he
told me three or four days ago that
Andrew Strauss and Tom Harrison the new
ECB boss under Colin Gray's wanted to
see him and we both agreed it could only
be for one reason and that would be to
rubber-stamp the previous bat because
Andrew Strauss has made no secret of his
hatred of Kevin Pietersen lot and all he
stands for but the bottom line is Kevin
Peterson gave up a very lucrative IPL
Indian Premier League contract to come
back to Surrey and play for nothing all
his salary is going to his crooked
Foundation which is a charity and he's
done that because the the boss of the
ECB said to him if you do that the score
runs you're back in the running for the
England being low batting lineup well
what more could he have done
he's just scored one of the highest
scores in the history of cricket and yet
the first reaction of Andrew Strauss was
to say you will not be playing this
summer I think most reasonably minded
cricket fans in this country will share
his sense of outrage Strauss says
there's still a question of trust there
is a trust issue because he tweeted a
gangster and texted against his England
colleagues when he was playing for
England and of course subsequently he
wrote that autobiography which made it
pretty clear what he thought of a lot of
his colleagues
well all these cricketers write books
Graham Swan wrote a very contentious
boat and carried on playing for England
for years our - it's under Andrew
Strauss so one rule for him one rule for
Kevin Pietersen Kevin Peterson's book
was a direct response to the tissue of
lies that the ECB deliberately leaked to
favor journalists the months after he
was sacked to try and justify what
they'd done
we were told with a dossier of 50
misdemeanors the Kevin had committed in
Australia not one of them has actually
been borne out by any substance or fact
the were no misdemeanors there is no
reason why he was sacked other than
certain people and that team were
jealous of him and didn't like the cut
of his jib well frankly if that is a
reason to not play professional sport
what England would have half a team in
almost any of the sports that we have
national teams in but do you think his
colleagues in the team could play with
him or trust them I think most of the
young players in the team love Kevin
Peterson if you took Jo route aside or
into a balance aside you too Bella side
you take some of the others in Australia
like Carberry they all talk very highly
about Kevin Peterson the problem has
only ever been with a small clique of
players the senior level led by broad
and prior and others and let's not
forget that Trust is a two-way street
some of that team last year or year and
a half ago started a bogus Twitter
account which ridiculed and mocked Kevin
Peterson on an almost hourly basis so
when it comes to trust this is not just
a question of Kevin Peterson it's a
question of the other players on the
team who were vindictively going after
him - and Andrew Strauss knows that but
has chosen to ignore that some of the
perpetrators like Stuart Broad are still
in the England team so there seems to be
one rule for him and one rule for
everybody else and Kevin Peterson at the
end of the day remains England's best
and most explosive batsman as we have
seen in the last 24 hours with this
incredible innings most of the best
sportsman in the world that come out
today after Andrew Strauss his statement
and said what on earth is going on this
is down to bad management Kevin Peterson
should not be dropped the England team
because Andrew Strauss doesn't like it
it should be dropped because he's not
good enough and nobody thinks he's not
good enough
you think Peterson has changed has his
as he grown up a bit as his character
changed as he become more amenable to
being a team player as a result of
what's happened to him in recent months
well this whole mythology about him not
being a team player Kevin Peterson was
part of the most successful team that
England cricket has ever had a retain
year period but what is being a team
player me when Manchester United won the
treble in 1999 two of their main
strikers Teddy sharing when Andy Cole
didn't exchange a single civil word to
each other in the entire season
who cares frankly if they're all happy
campers singing love songs to each other
in the dressing room I couldn't give a
monkey's I want them to score runs and
beat the Australians this summer and we
have a better chance of beating them
with Kevin Pietersen them without him
now has he changed I think he's got a
bit older I think he's got a bit more
mature
I think he's accepted some of the things
he did perhaps you know rubbed people up
the wrong way but he hasn't fallen out
of nightclubs drunk he doesn't take
drugs he's a great father he's a great
husband he's the hardest trainer in the
team and nobody can test that he's ever
done anything on the pitch to bring the
England shirt into disgrace or ignominy
and so the question remains what has he
done that's so bad that means he can't
play for his country other than annoy
Andrew Strauss
I mean his critics are saying that their
other English batsmen who are scoring
centuries and therefore it's crowded at
the top well why don't we ask the
Australian fast bowlers who they would
least like to see coming in in the
middle order for England this summer and
the number one person they would least
like to see is the guy but let's not
forget was the top scorer in the last
Ashes series and that's Kevin Peterson
he was the top scorer and then got
sacked I felt at the time that was
utterly ridiculous
I remain of that view English cricket
has collapsed since Kevin Pietersen left
the team after 10 glorious years of
success and frankly it's time that the
petty vindictive egos of the English
cricket ball were put to one side and
the interest of the England team the
country and the fans that pay these guys
wages were put first DAWs Peterson or
indeed do you think there's any chance
that he will make it into the test team
this summer
I think there's zero chance of Kevin
Pietersen making the team if Angie
Strauss is in charge with this blinkered
bigoted view of him so my solution would
be if we lose against New Zealand which
we might easily do in a couple of weeks
time and we lose the first couple of
tests against Australia which we might
easily do I would fire and just try and
bring back Kevin Pietersen because this
is personal
it's not about cricket it's not about
Peterson's ability even Straus admits
he's a fantastic batsman but the idea
that a man can score 355 runs and then
be taken into a room by Andrew Strauss
and told you're not playing the summer
for England is utterly ridiculous Piers
Morgan thank you for joining us